yes of does when you have this situation
and I'm actually not even going to tell
you I've raised a whole bunch of
questions you can see all the [ __ ] you
might want to raise your own questions
right but this question is actually
quite tricky right most of us didn't
have a good intuition for what this
looks of this number Wars so what the
fine animals have to do with this
situation well there are three
particular things they connect these two
ideas right the first is the first is by
doing it right final is about two things
okay and they happen again and again and
again so you raise it to some power
right and that's what the binomial
theorem allows us to do work out the
competitions for each one okay so for
instance if I have you know each one of
these times right next time you roll the
dice each time you roll the dice okay
you are either going to get killed by
Baltimore or you going to survive right
you are going to stay alive or you're
going to die okay what was the
probability of you killed by mobile on
each individual turn it's one out of six
right the opposite of that
the couple that is surviving which of
course is five out of six because there
are five equally likely options right
and then that that event right this all
this it unhung it played out right it
rolled as many times as you actually did
this all right so perhaps that number of
times okay you're rolling and rolling
and rolling sounds either this or that
this or that okay now I want you to now
think right what was the probability
what was the probability if we play just
one enormous game of rolling a
particular number of sixes right what
would be the most common number of sixes
to roll out of this many dice for an
Australian or be the most common number
of sixes okay now this is a bit tricky
to answer right is it going to be
exactly a six of those of those dice
what do you think
what is your what is your gut tell you
is that the most likely number eight
times you what this you remember these
obviously yeah so that's out of ten
right so you say 80% and don't forget
right some of you know this is really
gonna pull this out right mm-hmm
some of you have very very interesting
games so I just love that these doesn't
Steve mix it done right so you've got
first you've got raft freak of nature
wins four games in a row okay
some of you never won again and that's
you right hey yo you're this one right
yeah freaka me so you want for gays
right not only need to win for Gager but
two of his games
hey one in 5 turns exactly yes that's
right so you two consecutive right now
right next to Raph
you've got Tom who who died in this game
he died right and then the next one he
rescued though people that means he want
a six-letter six and then he rescued no
people again that's a six and then he
rescued no people again that's a nice
it's that's four sixes in a row right
what chances of rolling four sixes in a
row so here's my point but I'm still
gonna leave this as a perfect question
what makes is binary probably the first
thing I've already been handed right is
that there's one of two things happening
like there are only two options two
options per event it's a this or that
this or that which is what makes a
binomial expression perfectly suited to
expressly secondly every time every time
you rolled every time you roll the
chances were the same right the events
were identical to each other right so
that would be like if you were rolling
dice obviously it
if you were dealing our cars that would
mean you'd have to take a card out but
then in order for the next event to be
exactly the same probabilities
everything you'd have to put the card
back in right because otherwise the deck
has changed and it's no longer the same
event right so every day event has to be
the same one last thing that means our
binary probably is going to be soon as
this kind of thing if I'd asked you in a
more simple way okay I only want you to
roll it three times okay
and let's just say because obviously you
can't rescue everyone in three turns
what's the chance of just surviving for
three turns okay you don't need any
fancy B expansions for this right you
can just do this with the tree it's
really easy isn't it like three sets you
only have two outcomes every time
they've died nearby you're gonna get
eight at the end you remember I told you
overall tips for sweeter probability is
if there's not that many things just
list about it's not it's not crazy okay
ah but we didn't just do it three times
did we we wanted to win so you just kept
on rolling and we did it hundreds of
times
okay so not only you had two options per
ventless of binomial not only do you
want them identical so that's why you
can raise it to a power and do the same
thing over and over again but what you
have is a many staged event right and I
don't just mean two or three I know
that's like multiple events I mean what
and what's so sometimes this will be
lying okay experimental probability
suppose I've got a factory and it
manufactures like light bulbs or
something like that right well this is
outputting tens of thousands of light
bulbs every day right there are two
options it's gonna be a good light bulb
or it's a dud every event it's got the
same chance because it's the same
manufacturing process that produces
every month light bulb right and it's a
mini staged event if this factory only
made three levels then who needs to
worry about any fancy techniques like
this but if this number is enormous then
you don't want to draw a tree for that
right so we use binomials to do this